And then it also, I think the other thing too, it depends how many leads have you sent him?
Is this your first lead? Is this your fifth lead? Because if I've already set this guy three,
four leads, you got to remember guys, you don't need to wait until they close a job,
until they close a lead to go and run the call, right? Like Porter, did that guy close any of
those deals you sent him? No, his estimates are today. So he hasn't even done one.
I was just going to say, and sometimes you're going to send them a few leads. They're not even
going to get to the leads and you're going to close them. And you could just tell one of the
reasons Porter, Porter's got a really good example right now of momentum, the power of momentum. You
get that deal and you get that second deal and you get that third deal and you get that fourth
deal. Then you get that fifth deal. And my guess is his sixth and seventh deal. He's two deals away
from hitting 10 K guys in two and a half, three months. So that question, Theo, it depends on what
lead number you're at. And if you're asking like, like, are you asking because you're worried that
it's going to sound like you're desperate or are you asking because you think you should just send
it before he actually talks to the homeowner? I'm not really sure what you're asking, but just
remember you don't need them to close a lead. You actually don't even need them to run the lead.
You just like, if it feels right, it feels right. And you just go for it. Okay.